Hi, everyone. My name
is Dave Duggal.
I'm the founder and CEO of,
Enterpriseweb. really excited
to be presenting
to you today.
I I know there's a lot
of good speakers,
and, hopefully, you'll find,
our presentation,
relevant and compelling.
So, the topic is biz dev ops.
I I wrote up originally as
aligning the business and IT
with graphs, but I think in
person with graphs,
it's more appropriate to say
linking the business,
and IT with graphs.
And, we're gonna
just present,
how our utilization of graphs
and what motivates us
and the capabilities
and affordances,
that we offer.
So first, let me
set this up in
a nutshell. Enterprise web is
a cloud native
integration platform,
iPaaS.
So we're not a graph
knowledge base.
That's, we have one.
We incorporate a graph
knowledge base.
It is a part of our
overall, solution,
but we would
describe ourselves
as a cloud native
integration,
really a cloud
native integration
and automation platform.
So the iPaaS category has sort
of broad has, been broadly
conceived as sort of,
incorporating a lot of message
oriented middleware,
in a new modern cloud
native context.
So enterprise web
is an integration
platform. And the point of
enterprise web and
why it's relevant,
to the graph communities is to
radically simplify
data center,
and venture, and distributed
application design,
deployment,
and management.
you know, and if
anybody's worked
in that domain of, you know,
working with all the various
cloud native tool
chains, Okta and,
you know, Amazon Lambda and
other tools in the space,
they would know that this is,
as far as heavy
heavy engineering.
these things are
difficult even
for advanced engineers,
working through issues like
concurrencies,
asynchrony concurrency,
immutability, impotence.
These things are very
challenging for,
even the best engineers.
it's challenging to do,
and it's usually done in a one
off application basis.
So we're offering a platform
that makes event
driven applications,
model based event
easier to do. Right?
And it leverages,
as I mentioned,
a real time graph connected
operational model.
And I think that's
really an important
difference to call
out right away.
We're talking about
an operational
model. We don't call ourselves
we're not doing
knowledge apps per se.
Right? We use
a knowledge graph.
We connect that
to graph objects
in a business domain,
an application domain,
and we use that to essentially
create a context
aware information
system. Right? So that we can
control the whole
system through
shared domain semantics
and metadata,
but the intent,
the motivation,
the use is for business
applications.
so and the idea is any of you
working in the enterprise or
large organizations
know is that
organizations are becoming
increasingly fragmented and
creating
an umbrella abstraction
over the top of
their, distributed,
diverse dynamic
IT environments
is usually helpful to them.
we have customers
in life sciences
and telecom, on
awards in IoT,
etcetera. So we've
done this in
a variety of domains.
So it's a generalized
platform for,
graph for, distributed
applications.
So I saw this.
I know EK, the EKGF,
presented previously
and we had
a panel talk the other day.
And I saw this on
their website,
and I hope they
don't mind that
I I put it here with the link
and all the proper
representation here.
and I have to say I
completely agree,
with their, maturity model.
The only thing I would say is
that what they say is gonna be
available in twenty
twenty seven
is actually available today.
We enable this sort of graph
connected environment,
real time graph connected
environment today.
And that's, again,
bridging that
sort of knowledge
data and application data with
the intent of
enabling the digital
business. So, you know,
as to the digital
business, you know,
almost it's a very,
vague term,
just like agile and all these
other terms used in
the IT industry,
and it's been elusive.
Eighty percent of
businesses want it,
yet fifty from fifty
one percent of,
developers and architects that
work on doing digital business
transformation say they want
another job.
That's a pretty
astounding statistic.
you know, that's from November
nineteenth of this
year, so, a week ago.
A week or so ago, you know,
that half a developer's task
with actually realizing and
achieving this
digital business,
are going crazy.
They need they need help.
They need they need
better abstractions.
They need better
tooling to make
their job easy.
One of the problems here I'm
pointing out, and I
wanna make sure,
you know, I realize
many of you
are focused on graphs and and
some of you, I'm sure,
are on the operational domain
and the application domain.
Many of you are
are more doing,
you know, research
and knowledge
graphs and knowledge
applications,
data science. so,
I'm trying to give
some background here.
So one of the one
of the challenges
here, if you see
in the background
of this of this
slide, actually,
that diagram is
the Cloud Native
Computing
Foundation's landscape
diagram of their vendors.
That's what they expect people
to deploy. And it's
pretty insane.
you know, you're by the time
you're done integrating
all those tools,
you actually have
a static siloed
solution that's gonna
be super brittle.
Essentially, it's almost like
recreating the old
middleware stack.
So businesses need
to rationalize
solution architectures
to bring
order to the increasingly
fragmented operations.
And, of course,
our solutions,
this is the problem space,
and our solution space,
which we're gonna
focus on, is,
graph. So there are
too many tools and,
too many tools
and silos and too
little interoperability
and automation.
So IT needs
a practical approach
which abstracts away this
distributed systems
complexity.
It's just too darn
hard. Right?
It's, it's it's engineering,
it's architecture,
it's computer science,
it's state management,
it's met reliable messaging.
This is hard stuff.
and so the solution
is an enterprise
web, a real time
graph connected
operational model
where we take
the the business concepts,
types and policies that define
a business architecture or
business at large,
and we give it
to customers out
of the box. We
have essentially
a generalized graph domain,
so you're not
building this from
scratch every time.
We we provide a ready to use
model that includes all of our
cloud native comp concepts,
all the distributed
systems concepts.
We might call it
the twelve some
people who work in that space
would call it twelve factor.
All these,
concepts related
to working with
things like Kubernetes
and working
with events and working
with messaging,
that's all included
in the system
as are generalized
enterprise concepts,
people tables, you
know, security,
authorization,
organizational units,
all the base concepts that you
would need to start modeling
your organization
already included.
And you could then,
import your own models.
So whether you
have a RDF model,
a UML model, XML, or JSON,
one of the world's largest
telecoms gave us a JSON file
that represented
their information
model. We uploaded it,
did entity extraction,
algorithmic mapping,
and we brought it
into our graph
in seconds.
And these are very
big organizations
with very complex graphs,
and we're making that graph
tractable and
transparent for them,
something they
could easily see
and manage.
And then that graph
in enterprise web,
this the notion of enterprise
web is we don't
stop at the the
upper ontology.
We don't stop at
the knowledge graph.
We actually then model all
solution elements
or essentially
mappings to these
concepts, types,
and policies. And
when I say all
solution elements,
I mean not just data access.
Right? This is
not just a simple
little GraphQL toy.
We're talking about,
something that is
actually gonna,
take complex applications like
a a Cisco router, to,
to or an AWS Amazon
web services
endpoint, or
a business process,
or some other complex artifact
or an IoT, physical
IoT device,
and model those almost like
digital twins using
these concepts.
And then we're gonna
give the customers
or or they're gaining global
transparency and virtually
centralized management because
no mat despite
the fact that all
the connected elements might
truly be heterogeneous
and they
might be distributed,
we're making them look as if
they are the same.
We're making them appear as if
they're all local.
And we have
these representations
of them, these
proxies as it were,
these digital twins,
which they can
then use to manage
and configure with metadata.
And it becomes a single source
of truth because
we're actually,
because these are
software objects,
mutable software objects,
we're actually
logging all their
state as well. So we actually
have the state of all
these objects too,
So we can then use
them in processes.
And because we're
bringing this
all with graph,
it's giving us is dev ops,
which was the, you know,
subject of the title
of the talk.
Right?
Is, an upper ontology,
a knowledge graph to,
model your
organizational concepts
and technical
concepts. Right?
So systems concepts
and enterprise
concepts. And then,
a logical space where you're
mapping all of your.
And then the physical
space, the ops,
well, at some point,
these all hit the road.
Right? They're all residing on
databases or they're
all residing
in systems or physical devices
somewhere, and
all those things
have to be you have
to have access.
You have to do
certs and auths,
connect to things,
integrate with things.
You have to manage
networking.
there's a lot of
complexity that
it takes to make
that all easy.
To make things simple
is very complex.
Right? Making very distribute
systems simple is
a very complex
task task. It requires high
level abstractions and high
level programmability.
So, with this graph,
we essentially get,
essentially, ooda loops.
You know, many of you probably
are familiar with
this concept,
the, observe, orient,
decide, and act.
Right? Because we have this
because we're a system,
event driven system,
you can think of us as a cloud
native complex event
driven system.
We're gonna observe
events in our space,
things that we're
connected to.
We're going to then interpret
events against this graph
operational model.
Right? And then we're
going to make,
we're gonna translate policies
using metadata and,
relationships to,
to make decisions,
and then we're gonna
take actions.
Those actions are gonna be,
context enhanced,
and they're always
gonna be real
time because it's
an event driven
system. Everything
is happening
in real time,
and the system is
managing the consistency,
transactional
integrity, etcetera.
And when we say take action,
we're not just talking about
integration. We're
talking about
integration, orchestration,
automation,
and human tasks.
So in a single click
or a single event,
you might be actually
doing a thousand
separate operations,
translating objects,
connecting things,
making decisions,
and then we might be actually
configuring a remote device or
a remote function.
We might be reporting
to through the UI,
to a user, and that's all
happening in in real time.
So, that's autonomic control
loops using graphs.
So, the scope of graph here is
different then. Right?
We're not just
talking data and
functions. we're
not just talking
about data, but we're talking
about data and functions,
not just properties,
but properties and behaviors,
metadata and state,
queries and commands. Right?
We're controlling
things. Right?
Graph objects and
graph processes.
Right? so we have,
our our objects are dag tags,
directed acyclic graphs,
and our processes are directed
acyclic graphs. Right?
So everything is graph in
enterprise web,
and that gives us
some tremendous,
computational power.
They are at
the halfway point.
Perfect. Data integration and
service orchestration,
graph transaction processing,
and cloud native deployment.
So we're literally
using graphs
to support offer
one of the world's
largest telecoms.
We're actually doing
hybrid multi cloud,
support. Right?
Where they're actually using
enterprise web,
onboarding really
complex solution
elements that
actually support,
things like this
like this webinar,
the underlying
technologies that
support it,
doing that in four
g and five g,
and doing it in a hybrid multi
cloud way where,
their customers
don't know where
their service is running.
They could actually,
it could run-in AWS or Google
or in the telecom
zone cloud or in,
Microsoft or in IBM's cloud.
And the system is handling all
the complexity of mitigating
the protocols, the formats,
and even the service
distinctions,
configuration
distinctions between
those environments.
So, so, again, high level
distractions to enable high
level programmability.
So, picking that back down to
brass tacks, in
enterprise web,
everything is graph object.
I mentioned that.
all graph objects are mapping
to a common ontology.
types, concepts,
and policies,
I mentioned that.
And they're
persisted as loosely
coupled immutable typed self
describing software
objects with
REST interfaces. Right?
That's, you know,
you know, you know,
nice. Right? This
is a very rich
object with rich types.
These these are not,
simple objects and
simple types.
They're not, and
the types are,
programmable as well
and and extensible.
So these are not, you know,
hard coded types.
you know, this is
a system where
even the types are actually
graph objects themselves,
and all the typing
is dynamic typing.
So, and we're making
those complex
things again as
simple as possible.
All of these objects,
because everything
is an object
in in enterprise web,
that's an isomorphism.
So that gives us common
common objects,
give us common methods,
that gives us common controls
of these objects.
Because all these objects look
the same to the system,
we can apply common policy
management to all
these objects.
They're common,
common governance,
common security,
common policy management.
they're all indexed
the same way.
They're all tagged
They're all version controlled
the same way, and they're com
all of that is attracted
from the user.
If you wanna know,
if you wanna see
how it's done,
it's it's visible to
the system owner,
but it's it's
hidden because at
some level, the person
at the business
application level,
the business user
doesn't care.
Business user just
wants a reliable
system. So when we're
onboarding things,
or importing models
or onboarding
code packages or authoring
adapters for components,
it's all the same approach in
enterprise web because,
essentially,
it's all gonna be
through a modeling
environment.
It's gonna be
through a REST API
or a JSON based portal.
And essentially,
we're gonna create
an object template,
and that's gonna interact with
our type system.
And the type system is gonna
interact with
the upper ontology.
The upper ontology is gonna
validate the object.
It's because, you know,
between the type system and
the and the domain concepts is
gonna apply validations,
and then it's gonna attach,
entities and
implementations to
it automatically.
So these are typed objects
regardless of what
the object is.
If you I can import a Word
document in enterprise web,
it'll automatically introspect
that Word document,
do the entity extraction,
do the algorithmic mapping,
same thing for RDF,
UML, XML, or JSON.
But But it's
the same thing also
if you give me
a code package.
Right? So if you
give me, you know,
a a function, an app business
application, I can import that
application the same way.
I can take that code package
the same way,
index it, tag it,
etcetera. And I can
even allow you to,
we can even enable
you to other
adapters or things,
complex other
system components.
So it's, you know,
it's in as I mentioned,
is it iPaaS?
It's an integration platform.
So it's built for extension.
It's built to be open.
So even though that the system
is very comprehensive,
it's not a closed system.
It's completely open.
It can work in a very
federated manner.
The system will
generate properties,
autofill parameters.
It will also, generate full
blown interfaces.
And we're not talking about
swagger to the extent
that people
are familiar with that,
which just creates stubs and
then you still manually
integrate that.
Enterprise web, creates,
underspecified
interfaces and then,
does all the bindings
at runtime
based on context.
It manages all of
that for you.
So it's a very
interactive process.
All the objects
then are persisted
in a cloud native
backing store and,
as immutable objects.
And this method of doing this
is essentially a model driven
process itself
using those same
system technology.
It supports version
control as well,
so you can pass through your
updates and upgrades,
and it will version
all of this
in our system.
we wrap all of our objects in
software contracts,
which provides
hooks for security
governance and
compliance policies.
So, and I'm sure
I'll get a lot
of interesting questions
in the q and a.
I know I'm moving
very quickly,
but I I I really wanna express
sort of the breadth
and richness
of our system to you.
But the idea again is we're
trying to give
a system that is
both easy to use,
but also is responsible
and reliable,
right, out of the box.
Enterprise Web
deploys literally
in minutes as a cloud native
platform itself. It's
very lightweight.
It's completely
distributable.
And we want customers to get,
value quickly. So
we're providing
all of these things,
and we're enabling
them to then
build out their
solutions. objects.
You know, these
objects that are
wrapped in contracts can then
be declaratively
composed. Right?
Once you onboard an object,
it goes to that,
it's persisted
in the catalog.
Then you can go to a catalog,
point and click
in the catalog,
or make references to
the, the catalog,
and, the system
will handle all
of the integration. You.
Whether you're
composing services,
tasks, or aggregates, again,
see that sort of the notion
crossing
the boundaries between
the data space and
the application
space, the system's
gonna handle
both of those for you.
No manual integration.
The system does all,
all the binding.
Likewise, a process is just
another object in
enterprise web.
It's just another DAG object,
a directed acyclic
graph object,
with a set of loosely coupled
tasks bound by commissions.
So the the physics
of enterprise web,
the logic of
enterprise web, it's,
it creates something called
homoiconicity. Right?
Is that, objects,
and transitions are the same
thing in enterprise web.
It gives us this
unified theory,
a unified theory of types that
allows us to, again,
get a lot of process
optimizations.
tasks are all connected by
conditional links,
and it's all event
driven, event,
asynchronous and
concurrent. Right?
So, you know, really high
performance and and scalable.
So the functionality that
enterprise web is,
I just described how we model
processes as graphs,
and customers can
actually create
other processes and
and essentially
be creating new
capabilities in
enterprise web.
but we essentially
give you out
of the box all
the sort of message
oriented middleware,
the common message oriented
middleware capabilities,
but they're implemented as
serverless functions.
They're all called
on demand and
hydrated by the graph.
Again, that makes the system
very lightweight,
very efficient,
very scalable,
and the graph is
essentially in
control of
the services. Right?
So we have stateless,
serverless functions
and a stateful
graph. This graph actually is
hydrating these
services on demand.
So it's following
all the tenets of,
cloud native computing,
and we maintain all
the scalability,
resilient, durability,
portability of cloud native
computing while creating high
efficiency, you know,
information system.
and this is what we would look
I'm just about to wrap up my
slides here now.
this is what we would look at
the application as
an as an application,
and you could see that we're
northbound or ping pointing in
REST API or JSON UI
to customer systems,
portals, analytics, AI, ML.
Now think how exciting that is
for you guys who are data
scientists who are working in
knowledge graphs. Well, gosh.
We're a fact model
that you can
reliably call on
through a JSON
UI or a REST API, and
you can import it,
if you have the right
permissions,
you can introspect our graph.
You can not only,
look at our models,
you can actually
look at the run
time activity.
And also then our
system could then
make calls up
to higher level systems,
higher level
analytic systems,
for optimizations,
for broader
evaluations of state.
so enterprise web, you know,
one of the challenges
for the whole
graph space is, you know,
good inference is,
supported by good facts.
So we're a great
fact model for
great inference
models. Right?
RDF has its use case.
Semantic Web has
its use case.
This is not an either
or situation.
Actually, I would say we're
really complimentary.
and, that I believe
is essentially,
wrapping up the talk.
So how much time
do I have, Bill?
you got about two minutes left
on the talk.
Okay. So actually,
I do actually have
no slides here.
So so just going
more back into
the into theory, right?
So some of you are gonna be
familiar with, Tokes',
life cycle
information model and
this notion of, you know,
it's again a maturity
model like
just like the graph knowledge
communities maturity model.
And generally, most
people aren't,
stuck down at the level of
syntactic technical
interoperability.
And enterprise led was driving
people towards dynamic and
conceptual interoperability.
That's where you
really wanna be.
Right? And the way we do that
is that we're saying,
well, actually,
it's all software. Right?
So we have conceptual layer,
a logical layer, and
a physical layer.
And all of those really are
models in enterprise
web because
we're gonna bind
actually physical
implementations. Those are
something the the physical
implementations are derived
based on interaction
context in
real time.
It's the model space that we
preserve and, care
about. Right?
So, enterprise web is actually
sent has is using
the same data
structures, the same
graph object
construct, the same
methods for
the conceptual, logical,
and physical models,
that is an optimization
then for
how we can process
hyper efficiently
and, you know, use knowledge
graphs to actually
do real time
applications. And
just for fun,
what does that really
translate to?
It's turtles all
the way down.
Recursive layers
of abstraction.
I mean, this dev ops,
some of you might be,
familiar with that that saying
turtles all the way down.
But the idea is that
the the universe
is be is, on the back
of a turtle,
and that turtle is standing on
top of another turtle,
and that turtle is sitting on
top of another turtle.
And then when the conversation
asks what's holding
that up that turtle,
you're supposed to say,
let's change
the conversation.
but the idea is
that's recursive
layers of abstraction.
my name is Dave Jagal.
I'm the oh, here's
some article
references for you.
if you want, I
believe this deck
will be shared,
and hopefully these links will
be active to get the decks.
you could, you know,
obviously look us
up and learn more,
or simply contact me.
And we'd always be
delighted to talk,
demonstrate, and
we, of course,
just love talking
about these ideas.
We love talking about computer
science and we love talking
about graphs. So thank you for
your time today.
I really look forward
to your questions.
I'm absolutely sure you guys
won't be shy.
I know many of you and,
and I hope you won't
be too rough on me.
Well, thank you, Dave.
And, yes, indeed,
you already have
a question from
the audience here.
it's from Jim, who's asking if
it's possible to
make a distinction
between existing plant and
deprecated assets. I'm sorry.
Oh, yes. Absolutely.
So everything is everything is
an object in enterprise web.
All the objects
have life cycle
management. all
of the concepts
in the ontology are objects.
They all have life
cycle management.
The ontology itself
is an object.
It's the set of concepts,
types and policies.
It is an object and it is life
cycle managed. So we actually
have something called
the model manager,
and the model manager actually
gives you a vehicle for the,
data scientist or
architect that is,
generally running or
owns the business
architecture, let's say,
to go in there and control and
then publish, new versions,
of the model. and so you can
call that a design time,
responsibility if you'd like.
and so the, model graph model
is fully open and extensible,
introspectable, navigable.
so that's a that's
a great question,
though.
So everything is an object.
All objects are
version controlled.
They're all indexed.
They're all tagged.
They're all searchable.
again, we're
working in the life
sciences, telecom,
and other general
enterprises.
you know, telecom
is considered
one of the hardest industries
to work in. They haven't we're
in production.
They haven't been
able to break it,
and they've imported their own
information models,
and they've managed
it that way,
and they found it
very extensible.
So and they use us they use it
as an abstraction over other,
technologies as well.
So great question.
I have a read one as well,
which I think is
kind of related.
At some point, you
mentioned that,
you treat all the checks and
transitions as
the same thing.
would you like to
elaborate a little
bit on that?
Because, you know,
it's not something I guess,
if if you have,
software engineering
or technical
background, it's not something
you can wrap
yourself your your
care needs to be around.
Yeah. It it it you
it is I pointed
it out because I
thought I think
some people will
all appreciate it.
It is a it is
a complex concept.
If you think about it,
the more transformations you
have to do in your pipelines
other than let me back
up another step.
The only thing
that the business
cares about is their logic and
the objects they
have access to.
We'll stop. No one
in the business
has ever cared
about technology.
It's a utility for
them to do their job.
That's it. That doesn't mean
technologies isn't important.
So in that context,
the more transformations
the more
complex my tool chains,
the more complex my
middleware stacks,
even a semantic web stuff,
the more the more connections
I have between the things and
the more transformations that
happen through
those pipelines,
and, yes, you can
do optimizations
and things that we
are all clearly
doing lots of
transformations.
But, really, what
you'd like to
do is just do transformations
in and transformations out.
And you like to,
you'd like to
actually have your
system to be as unified as
possible to do as many things
as possible under
a common model.
And so if you can
actually have
your process, your
process models
so so there's two things,
a couple things.
A unified object
model, gives you,
common methods.
That's a very powerful concept
in computer science.
So just in general,
if I make everything
look the same,
then I can apply
common policies
and common controls on it.
That's just a low
even if you're
heterogeneous underneath,
that's an abstraction
that gives
me lots of power.
If I can do that both over,
objects and I could do it over
processes, that's
even more power.
we had this back
in the mainframe,
but the mainframe
wasn't distributed.
The mainframe had
this kind of,
isomorphism, this kind
of homoakinicity.
But really it's just another,
it's just an abstraction,
and if you really wanna look
into it I'd recommend,
my friend Milner,
who's no longer with
us. Rest in peace.
but, you know,
we like to think
we stand on the shoulders
of giants.
Strachey, Milner, Malone.
you know, many many many of
the great greats oh,
we like we like fielding.
Of course, we like
Tim Berners Lee and,
Deborah McGinnis and and and,
Jim Hedler, all
those all those,
folks, we we we stay
on the shoulders
of giants of giants.
We're particularly
fond of of Milner.
Milner wrote the ML language.
You know, we're very close to
those ideas.
But his life's work was trying
to unify object
theory and process
theory, and he died not having
completed it. He
completed it.
We we created that.
He would describe
that as abstract
rewriting and
transition theory.
These are very esoteric areas
in computer science,
but the bottom
line is it's what
gives us the power to
do what we we do.
K. Well, I have
a a tough choice here.
I can ask you a very direct
question from from Jean,
or I can ask you
a more complicated
question from me.
And since times run out,
I'm going to go with a direct
question from Xin,
who's asking how
much does it cost,
and are there several packages
with different levels of
capabilities and
different prices?
So it's actually super easy.
It's one price.
It's based on your usage.
We've partnered with
the world's well,
you know, I I
can't we're about
to announce shortly that we've
partnered with,
world's largest cloud,
providers. It it could
run on premise.
It could run, on any cloud of
your choice. It could
run as a hosted
service, and, you literally,
are charged by your
CPU utilization
and your number of users.
And we've actually
made it fairly
inexpensive, because we want
customers to like it,
and then we want it to scale.
We don't wanna put barriers,
in between them and the sale,
and we don't wanna
put barriers
on them scaling it.
Because what
happens with every
one of our customers is they
tend to start small because
they're excited about it,
but they wanna start small,
start on a single
use case that
maybe is a a hard problem,
and then they expand
the abstraction
over more and
more use cases to
generalize the and
take advantage
of it as a platform.
And that's what we want.
We don't care if you start
literally using
it for a single
single application or single
line of business or
single use case.
It won't cost much
to start at all.
We generally start giving
customers with, some parties.
We generally do
pilots anyway.
Those are generally
at no charge.
We host them. We make them
available to serious
interested parties.
So, and all
the objects that you
create on top of
enterprise web
are yours. Think of us as just
being the enabling
technology.
If you create objects
in enterprise web,
those are your objects.
everything can be exported as
RDF or XML or
anything else that
you want to be.
so, we're not binding you.
It's an open system.
It's meant to enable.
It's not meant to hinder.
We really tried
as the company's
name is Enterprise Web,
we've tried to
align our interests
with the enterprise
interests.
Thank you for that
question, though.
If there's time,
I'd love to answer that hard
question too because
I I love it.
It.